[Applaudissements]
l'écurie merci d'être avec nous tu avais
prévenus à partir d'aujourd'hui on fera
des olympiades les chéris des sons la
perte de tp mp on va jouer à ce coup
teboul chaque chroniqueur va avoir deux
bouteilles une bouteille d'ailleurs une
bouteille dans chaque main dans lesquels
il y aura des 1000 faut secouer les
bouteilles pour faire passer les be d'un
côté d'une autre bouteille
[Applaudissements]
anne nivat est avec no mercy mercy mercy
avec la ville est magnifique et jean
jacques bourdin mots d'amour avec la ja
troisième édition vous faites encore
plus on va pas trahir un secret ils sont
ensemble
voilà je préfère vous le dire au départ
j'étais pas pour voilà et ça fait quinze
ans que ça dure c'est ça oui vous êtes
rencontrés comment sur dans une
interview dans une interview à m6 mais
c'est jean-jacques m'interviewer à tva
ne revenait d'afghanistan elle venait
d'écrire un livre sur l'afghanistan
passionnant à la fin d'interview j'avais
trois minutes parce qu'un flash bat
isabelle connais bien c'est un flash
j'avais trois minutes parce que je ne
sais pas et c'est partir comme ça moi
j'étais en je sors de mon studio
je sors de mons où je vais la voir jeudi
vous êtes encore là a invité moscou à
l'époque on est encore là quand même
temps me dit deux jours je vous invite à
déjeuner demain
j'ai deux questions à vous poser on
était devant l'ascenseur l'ascenseur
était employé es ce que vous avez un
numéro de téléphone que vous êtes à
paris 2
est ce que vous les déjeuners avec moi
avant de rentrer à moscou voilà voilà
il a été hyper rapide l'immense star
américaine du basket qui est décédé à 41
ans dans un accident d'hélicoptère los
angeles et kobe bryant c'est un des plus
grands joueurs de basket de tous les
temps des plus grands sportifs de tous
les temps j'ai appris ça hier jeu
franchement je n'arrivais pas à y croire
bonsoir bonsoir cyril hanouna bonsoir
jean jacques trappes dans les yvelines
oui les yeux dans les yeux la dar k et
la race rappelé je n'avais jamais
entendu parler de ces toiles arcaraz sa
balade arcas et la rigolade
voilà c'est de l'arabe et lara sera
celle angoisse voilà moi c'est ma mère
disait trouver ça vous avez un peu
d'angoissé quand on est l'antenne est ce
que vous êtes angoissé parfois
franchement pas souvent plus passionnant
plus maintenant
non je suis content prêt motion angoissé
plus tôt le lendemain avec les audiences
glacer les os derrière c'est à dire
après moi j'attends 9h01 les audiences
je suis pas bien mais ça ne peut pas me
réveiller je peux pas me lever du lit
tant que j'ai pas vu les audiences
d'hier nous avons démarré les olympiades
alors sachez que ce matin au bureau je
vous raconte encore une marca qui nous
arrive
on a reçu un coup de fil du comité
olympique a way qui nous a dit on peut
pas appeler cette séquence saison la
place sinon faut payer une très forte
somme c
on continue à payer une très forte somme
mais aujourd'hui ça s'appelle les babas
olympiades j'en ai pris lors des 5 3
vous allez prendre des balles de ping
pong vous allez devoir m regardez vous
allez devoir faire un rebond et m les
balles de ping pong dans l'éveil by what
we dance en phase ii et benji qui vous
donne le relais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est très beau jeu d'apple
tous les jours actuellement m'arrêtent
dans la rue me dise où on en est de
gilles et 2 fatton j'ai écouté les
conseils de baba love
non vous aviez recommandé le black out
oui l'émission hier c'est fini à 21h11
mais les six aimant oui eh bien je n'ai
pas eu de contact avec fatto avant 21h30
à feu 19 minutes de black out ou fous de
ma gueule c'est non d'habitude je
l'appelle tout de suite à 27'' nudistes
bagdad en date celui envoyé un message
et elle m'a rappelé j'ai décroché
et alors on exprime zone c'est pour moi
la règle les animatrices et je les dis
ici
maintes et maintes fois même quand elle
n'était pas là merci à la reine des
abeilles et arrêts des animatrices qui
faillit lui miel elle a une qui fait de
l'audience
sophie d'abord et avec la police
franchement france télé lightroom qu'ils
ont fait fort avec la lettre on adore
mais je sais qu'à certains chroniqueurs
qui ont écrit une lettre à quelqu'un qui
leur étaient chers cher j'ai remis une
poésie à mon niveau littéraire c'est
dire si ces faibles sans me juger dès le
début dans tpm paix tu m'as accepter ta
culture tu as eu un peu me l'inculquer
chaque semaine c'est toi c'est avec des
sushis qu'on a dîné c'est vrai quand
j'ai pété un plomb seul toit savait me
calmer quand j'étais triste et amer dans
ta chambre d'amis un lit tu dépliait de
mes amis aujourd'hui et puis le pilier
alors merci d'être mon meilleur ami et
pas que dans tpm p
[Musique]
mais bon je vous adorez cette séquence
là me fait plaisir cette séquence est
quand même est tellement merveilleux qui
dévalorise dans l'émission ils font
faisant croire qu'il est radin qui n'est
pas sensible accès à naître qui est tout
en sensibilité que je l'adorais
évidemment tu me vois tellement que tu
ne me regardent plus pourtant moi je
n'ai d'yeux que pour toi si je
travaillais moi je passerai mes journées
à tomates et en replay à écouter des
paroles qui coulerait dans ma gorge qui
ont du bon miel
je serai toujours là pour toi je t'aime
serre ils disent qu'ils ont tous les
jours je vois plus que mes enfants ça
malheureusement là ce soir c'est la
grande finale des babas olympiades vous
mener 2-1 face à moi merci merci
sachez offrit une épreuve du jour
comptera donc deux points l'épreuve du
jour une balle de ping pong un gel
antibactérien il faudra jongler
sophistes heures deux stars deux fois
celui qui fera le meilleur score sur
deux prestations d'accor sophie si tu
gagnes tu fais gagner
je vais le montrer tu feras gagner au
chroniqueur ce magnifique pour chaque
chroniqueur faut chaque chroniqueur 1 2
3 4 5 6 laisse lire pression tu as perdu
ton badge à 5 06 13 14 15 7 minutes 9 21
22 23 24 29 31 32 33 34 35 36 à temps
quatre cadres a dit qu'avec 1 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 tout stress c'est terminé c'est
perdu
il nous a rejoint docteur frédéric
saldmann l'air si d'être avec nous on
n'est jamais mieux soigner tout par
suarez pour retarder l'orgasme
il ya d'autres techniques que de penser
à sa grand-mère [ __ ] lecoq
rabaisser dans le livre oui alors c'est
quoi alors c'est important parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d'hommes qui souhaitent
d'éjaculation précoce merci on sait
qu'on a un sur deux on est monté ici
vous savez tout ça à sa part dans la
minute c'est à des menaces
c'est insupportable alors alors l'astuce
est très simple au moment où on sent que
ça va venir
il faut inspirer il ya eu un écartement
des cuisses à avoir à ce moment là il
faut écarter les cuisses et des cartons
des cartes avec vous sans accroc match à
l'intérieur bien évidemment barça et on
reprend la main tellement on reprend sa
main mais non à les allaiter ou lamar il
ya une autre peau capcir il a fait
semblant d'essayer de comprendre un
débat d'intello entre guillaume de
tonquédec eric naulleau alors qu'en
réalité n'a purgé que dalle
en fait oui c'est vrai
ca
mais non
donner la balle à ces prévenus de
gémellité pas pouvoir je suis allé voir
le pont bras communes françaises sont
venues
on verra mais j'ai rien c'est quoi ce
charabia qui appartiennent avec qui vous
embrouiller le plus dans l'émission pas
de leurs maux
[Rires]
[Musique]
vous êtes quand même le match pour son
équipe
c'est très bien on sait bien